Hello Berlin and welcome to this almost symmetrical shot
Let's look at funny memes in Goa
Scattered in Florida. That's right. We also have regular content on this channel
What this is not minecraft
I'm sure there's gonna be a plenty of Minecraft memes in here. Let's just get real
Everyone is just obsessed with minecraft mass hysteria of Minecraft there
Are are the things in life that can bring joy Who am I kidding? But at least we can try
Let's watch watch to the end for a surprise. Oh my god. The first clip is minecraft
Creeper oh man, I'm done. Hey, look the second game is my I
Already know I'm gonna like it. There's smash like
I
Don't know about that actually
But it is mine crap. So yes. Oh
My god, can you imagine Avengers minecraft edition? You know, usually I cringe out all these corporate crossovers
But please start combining minecraft wood stuff. I would love to see that happen spider-man minecraft
Okay, so three minecraft videos in a row. Let's do this. Let's see if we can make me Scout that oh
My god
That's so sad, oh
I get it. He can't read. Okay, I got it. I got the joke. That's a legit edit
Well done, but did it make me scat that I don't think so. Come on guys. Here's one of my favorite. Oh my god
It's only Minecraft. Oh
She's bringing over the sheet. That's so cute
You're saying hear hear oh, that's right. I understand Nihon go. That's okay Oh
Well done spread proud of you keep it up, okay, it's all mine crying. Okay. I don't even know there's no way around it. Oh
My god
What I'm saying combined minecraft with anything it's still gotta be ten out of ten Oh what
That's a good meme
Too much damage couldn't handle it fully understandable
What they're just laughs at a non Minecraft meme
Get it together Felix. You're better than this. All right, here we go
Isn't that rare to see a baby riding a spider cuz it happened once with me and that most like oh my god, oh
my god
They can't do that Kelly that's illegal. Wait a minute
Only true minecrafters can understand. Okay, just wait one second
All right now I'm ready to watch
Minecraft understand
Oh my god, these Eddie's are crazy. Hey girl, how you doing? I'm about to go to bed
Goodnight go
That's pretty good I'm impressed by these, okay
Unusual videos. Oh my god. What's that? The Joe Joe actress? I
Need to watch yo, Joe, I'm too busy playing Minecraft get the freak out of my room. Okay. Here we go. Alright
Hey, are you okay?
That's a good name well done you made me Scott that and can be appreciate for
20 I don't wanna interact with it because I'll ruin it. Yeah. Oh, so there they have G fuel in bottle I can now
It's really good, but it make me very burpy slurpy
Haha, check it out. Enter code PewDiePie, you know the drill Co PewDiePie everytime?
Took a picture of myself every day for 10 years. I love this. These are so cool. Oh
my god
He's aging so much
Wow
It's becoming an oblivion character oblivion every scene my god
That's so nice
Good for him, man
Oh dear me died
Back from the LK
All right, someone has too much spare time, that's all I got to say about that
I mean anyone that does these picture everyday? Come on, what are you doing? I know you're taking a picture every day
I got that but why why is it weird that I just want to see the enemy girl again? It was so cute
All its real gamers understand pain
Philosophers say suffering defines man, but why why or why there's so much pain from Minecraft?
Ok
That's pretty cool that was garbage loop come on let me try it
This is Oh
Remember gamers playthrough over it's vengal. Bye. Bye. How has been live how
Well play wait Squidward
Sounds like the same guy every time yeah, he's still there. He's still out there asking Squidward a DAB. Oh
My god, I've seen this. Yes, I need to do this
Let's get really any tips. I need to do this
What are those like candles or poser
You know not to put that in there one late night is that you know what, you know, buddy freakin sweet
He called us up Microsoft. I got two words Pistons and long objects Bill Gates
Be like haha company contenido scar
Is that fart real I always think I thought about that I mean I think about that much I've thought about it
is it a real for it sounds so authentic, but at the same time I'm like
I don't think it's real but I kind of want it to be real but at the same time I
Really don't want it to be real. Is it real girl who made this video?
let me know recreate it so I can know thank you Sarah point zero one of
hands or not
As oh
No, I did not laugh at that stop stop sending me these awful memes it's not funny then laughs not funny
- oh
My god
Where do you have that one moment with your enemy? Yes. What is this?
Who made this
Donald Trump II like game cause violence everyone be like
Yeah, I
Played video games and I never did violet. Alright, he makes this man makes point. I'm not saying anything
I'm just naming everyone only 200 IQ people can figure this out
I mean can figure this out you dumb schmuck. Learn English. Alright
What is this just some sweet redstone contraptions
Alright, alright, I respect it. This is the lock to enter his house. That's the name the paper
I'm gonna put it in the dropper. Okay papers, please. All right. All right. Oh
Well played well played very nice. Oh my god, he did it the absolute man land Johnny D
the legend
Yes
Let's hear it look at him. Oh
Man
That's ten out of ten men
Ha ha ha
That's forgive me ha
Gamers. Hope you enjoyed this episode of scatter their below. Really. Yes minecraft will be out tomorrow. Ok
My gosh we do have new merch
I feel like I have to tell you I have to tell you imagine watching PewDiePie's Minecraft videos and not wearing the merge cringe
Trains bruh. Go to represent that calm sighs Peter Pan. Check it out. You don't have to don't have to don't have to
But you share
Brofist at a hundred million and a twelve-hour minecraft livestream. Let's get a gamers buy
What you never played super simulator
You know, it's fun right I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not convinced yet. Okay
I'll cut you a deal the game is available for free and that's a great price